welcome to this video total rush near no
total row f whatever from laysia this
malaysia yep ok let's see Queens gambit
yarder Bishop f4 line usually it serves
me quite well ok
hmm yeah
so we have a target Cooper variation
here with me being a tempo up right yeah
maybe look see one that's still with the
temple up it's it's not like not like
much okay I can can take what okay it's
both good let's see you form a now it's
some very nice choice yet between
various good continuations this is a
thing strong wherever you cannot really
take and now I have both a five and the
capture it's both are very good for wide
the matter of taste I guess you five
it's not clear though it's both good
this is playing for the attack here with
Queen d3 okay
I still take a pond if you give it to me
okay should I have still play Queen you
three I can and then play route see one
doubling on the C file um yeah how to
win here probably many good ways to play
yeah is trying to get its Queen trapped
with chief or maybe
okay so G for Queen g6 it is almost
wrapped it's very very close but i can
after Queen g6 I can also just trade the
Queen Alice's this is a disastrous end
game but moving the Queen shirt should
win Jang almost wins the the black queen
so I take care that's really useless to
take when you when you get get this this
alternative and the only Mukhlis Queenie
six but then i have worked 12 c 6 under
distract
Bishop f5 was also possible Joe yeah it
has no square anyway I can also retreat
it here to e2 red black screen and snow
square anyway black resigns yeah this
opening was a bit too bad it's this year
I mean this is a bit was funny i we have
a relatively normal position here but
after Bishop t6 Bishop g5 Bishop e7 I'm
a tempo up on the tar take over and yeah
because I've took two moves to go to g5
and he choked her three moves to go to
e7 and yeah he's putting this on the
board c6 yeah you can with all those
move those blackest black is worse quite
quite substantially your liking h6 a as
a tempo and you a tempo down anyway and
after this he must play e takes after
which before gives me a tattoo cover
with to tempo up so it should be better
for white but still black is Sam is on
the board after this um I don't think
you can still play this position it's
very bad ya hear you you're basically
lost giving away at least upon Jim here
here you don't need to analyze the
compass on plus two already this is so
bad c6 v5s that sets an unplayable
position the sea pond is basically gone
and guindy three yeah he's putting moves
on the board here but it's it's too late
it's too late him and this is basically
finito this the sea pong is also deadly
week yeah so nothing not much to look at
him like his assist 22 worse yet you
were to keep playing
ya hear this he puts this on the board
g66 and over the light squares are a
two-weekend okay thanks for watching